yeah
morning Millennials welcome to take two
we had some tech issues we just thought
we'd start fresh fresh or as my people
say alfresco I thought we have a clean
slate or as my people say tabula rasa
what you've never heard of that I think
it's Latin for clean slate I never heard
of that it's a nice term huh hey we're
gonna have the Latin camper isn't it
interesting that Latin is like the old
language do you speak gibberish no I
don't either guys do the GU cool if it
gets true the GU very cool oh did I just
say neither do I it's true I said I do
it's true oh because basically it's like
between syllables you have to say like
in that so it's like this vase it I
guess for the gate so we say ok say
mosquito mosquito is hard cuz it's two
syllables so it's like I guess you know
no it's like maybe the ski and get this
go okay welcome to the morning toast
today is hump day so Jackie's gonna help
me later in the show it is Wednesday
April 3rd and all I keep thinking about
is how close Coachella isn't like I'm
not prepared I am obviously like in
terms of things to pack but also like
things in which to feel mentally
physically spiritually emotionally
emotionally literally yeah I have like
one good outfit and even then I'm like
not even confident in that one I think I
need like four more I have like five bad
outfits which is worse than one good one
we're just four bad outfits equal one
good one perhaps but like I feel like
all the outfits are bad and then
together they're okay it's like a
symphony but what's happening for me
it's like it looks like I'm gonna be
wearing like little like Easter dresses
I don't know if that's the vibe but
that's just where I'm headed it's like
brunch look it's also like what is the
bad I don't know I guess you get there
and you find out well I feel like the
vibe for the day in the night everyone
like changes all of us major bloggers do
a change I can you included yourself in
there I mean all of us we are major
major and so during the day I think you
look like cutesy like brunch style
revolve and then at night you are like
country-western NASA interpreting that
combat boots because the wind yeah every
once in dramatically with the bandanas
around they're like this they like that
it does to the sand in the desert it's
like I wore the man town I was like oh
no the dust like I didn't see a piece of
dust it was so stupid because it was in
your
you can see everywhere Coachella is just
like so dramatic
they are they really I can't wait to
join them the two biggest drama queen
they can wait but we're gonna make it
life's what you make it so let's make it
rock what a busy month for us April
always is because you have Hotel
stagecoach whether you choose to go or
not you pass over you have Easter you
have my shows in Orlando and Clearwater
this weekend tickets available at girl
with no job calm you have the toast
anniversary and you have the biggest
interview of your life tomorrow I know
and I think it's we can say no we're
going to get questions like we're gonna
I don't want to juice it there's nothing
to jinxing like I think that it's
happening no one said otherwise
and I literally no third tomorrow we are
interviewing in a podcast only episode
because we work around her schedule
which will be released on Friday because
it's expensive to be her Erika Jayne
tomorrow yeah that's right you heard
that right you've heard it right
Lisa who that's right what a great time
for us to be talking to her like so much
going on in the ecosystem of Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills I know but
we have to be careful because I'm sure
she's so tired of talking about it like
she looks over at his hell already on
the show right and so I don't I don't
want to get bogged down bite by puppy
ate no me neither I just want to I want
to tell her like how impressed I am with
her for 1 million reasons like she's an
extremely accomplished woman but I
believe that her biggest accomplishment
in the most impressive thing about her
was within one week of meeting Lisa
Vanderpump she completely understood who
she was and said sniper from the side
and that's exactly what she was and it's
like even people on Twitter who have
been watching this show for however many
seasons now um
fail to see what Lisa Vanderpump is
cooking up oh my god when I will talk
about Beverly Hills after the show I
went on Twitter just to like confirmed
temperature on this and apparently like
we're a nation divided completely and I
had the most interesting like debate
with Chloe Troutman on Instagram stories
last night because she's like Chloe from
siesta key she is like hardcore for LVP
because she's a sniper from the side no
he's a fellow sniper but wait I made the
best comparison I want to read our
conversation in a no shade sort of way
Chloe also I feel like we truly need to
have like remember when it was Cal
versus Bethenny we want to have like a
presidential debate yes and we need to
now and then I was thinking about
Carroll versus Bethany and I'm pretty
sure I can say like I don't think I've
ever been on the wrong side of
housewives history and I'm not about to
start now
teen Kyle okay Chloe hold on and
actually Chloe's a sniper from the side
but she always owns up to the [ __ ] that
she does and apologizes that's where she
differs for the Lisa Vanderpump and
that's why she's a beloved figure so
Chloe goes Chloe goes team Vanderpump
and I'm like oh no she goes I love her
I'm like don't be on the wrong side of
history
she said Claudia that show is wouldn't
be what it is without her yes how Khloe
feels matter like I am right here
Chloe's coming from I said yes if she
said yes it finally caught up to her but
every woman on that show should thank
her I said she should think every single
woman she destroyed on her way to
becoming this huge restaurateur because
of this show she has managed to ruin
people's lives and friendship so that
without ever actually getting involved
and now she's benefiting the most off of
other people who open up their entire
lives for the show Clare responds you
have it so so so wrong she didn't
destroy anyone it's just a real little
reality show drama
she made the show interesting without
her there's no storyline in any season
I said Brandi Glanville she tried to
take down your londa she tried to take
down to read she tried Camille in like
2011 she constantly has other people
doing her dirty work
she made Brandi bring up the fact that
Adrienne had a surrogate she made Brandi
bring up Bella Hadid SDU I remember she
had Camille bring up the fact that
Taylor Armstrong husband was abusive she
had Lee said we're gonna bring up
Munchausen the disease about Yolanda and
finally she attended bring up the dog
thing about terrine and she had Brandi
bring up the magazines for another one
she was exactly the show would have no
storyline without her I said no it would
still be there none of those storylines
have anything to do with Lisa she's had
the luxury of enjoying all the benefits
of the show without ever having to
expose herself or be vulnerable and as
someone who's on a show you should find
that especially infuriating Chloe Sheen
respond Wow yeah I'm just I'm not ready
for another like polarizing I thought
really we had all gotten behind and this
is what confuses me when Andy Cohen's
baby shower happened and Lisa Rinna was
just the talk of it like the toast of
the town and everyone loves Lisa and I
think she's literally like America's
most beloved housewife but so how all of
a sudden have you turned on her you
think she's like some follower hyena no
by the way the consensus on Twitter is
that Lisa Rinna was the one to plant the
stories that's what a lot of people are
saying because like she said she knows
the way that banner from talks
the creature so it's like if you know
that my vana from talks maybe you could
leak a story pretending to be this
Vanderpump I don't think so no I mean
the way that Lisa Vanderpump sold the
story to radar and then did like the TMZ
Tim Ken is like look how genuine she
looks like I can't it starts to this
like she could win or as II yemen's a
tester you know this is like a low-level
acting and it's so funny they're still
nice okay wait we're in time later okay
we'll get to it just in case for those
of you don't watch everything Hills you
can tune on at the end but like I'm
really annoyed like I feel like Bethany
versus Carol right now where I don't
know one day I will be justified but
right now it's like you guys we're gonna
get duped again on an eighth season
right now everyone is really like
looking at this season as if it's a time
like as if the other seasons don't exist
it's like okay there might be some flaws
with this story I'm not really
understanding the whole thing but let me
not forget the history of Lisa
Vanderpump you can't just erase all that
because in this instance like Teddy did
lie a little bit in the beginning no
this is a whole story this is Lisa
Vanderpump's entire motto and you cannot
forget what happened before it's a patch
don't be dumb yes it's a pattern and
maybe they chose the wrong instance to
take her down maybe it was too weak and
too thin agreed but here we are but a
takedown is happening so get on board
yeah totally
okay we can tell you about um my C
medium he has to go through all the
things that we talked about hearing take
one so right before I mean right after
we wrapped yesterday Alex came up to us
we were talking about CBD and Alex who's
one of the techs here he said he
actually like had something in his hand
he was like his family is in the CBD
industry and to try this chocolate he
was explaining all the benefits and I
was like really down to do it and I like
had the little thing in my bag the whole
day and then I got home I put it on my
nightstand and at like 10 o'clock I
thought about taking it and then I'm
like we were supposed to do together
yeah right after I finish Vanderpump
rules I'm like I'm to go to bed I mean
Beverly Hills I'm like I'm gonna go to
bed and I'm I take this chocolate and
I'm like looking at the chocolate and
I'm like oh it's totally like heroin
like I just thought it was like you
thought it was inedible I thought it was
actually me like I'm people and people
like I was doing the whole story on
Instagram and people were like see me
these not bad for you and you're so done
I'm like I'm not doubting whether or not
CBD is gonna make me I I'm just not sure
that this is CBD because I read the
ingredients
it said hemp extract some okay is that
THC or CBD THC is the one that makes you
high CBD is like the non psychoactive
drug or whatever so you really did
recently I did because I was freaking
out and then I just like gave in and
took it and this second I ate it my
heart was beating so fast I was like I'm
an aside I'd like a tonight I'm gonna be
up all night like my worst nightmare
like I'm really not a weed smoker so as
I'm like freaking myself out of doing
all the sweet church all of a sudden I
just feel like this wave of like warmth
and relaxation come over me and I just
felt so like at peace and then I fell
asleep and had the deepest weirdest
dreams my dream I said it was my wedding
day and I was getting married at this
huge estate which back in the day used
to belong to our Kellie where he held
girls hostages but now it was just like
a house I'm about to walk down the aisle
and there's a hold up and I'm like
what's going on and the police are there
and they said there's another girl in
the house so my wedding is delayed I'm
like freaking out screaming crying
sweating looking at everyone what's
going on who cares all of a sudden were
wish there's open gunfire were shooting
our Kellie someone on my team shoots our
Kelly then our lawyer comes in and says
that we actually own this house because
we have custody rights or some [ __ ] I
don't know I never ended up getting
married and but our Kelly died and I are
you marrying you know it wasn't
important because the person wasn't
there I never got to walk down the aisle
and see maybe I'll finish the rest of
the chocolate tonight and find out stay
tuned
anyways I thought you weren't taking it
so I didn't take it but I'm glad to hear
that one of us had a great night I did
want to be the guinea pig but then I
called you at like 11:00 and you
wouldn't take it so uh because you you
didn't say that you had taken it I would
have taken it with you but then also it
was too late but I did sleep like [ __ ]
because I'm just not into I slept so
good part CBD part many mattress but I'm
just really you're loving your purple
match I'm really grateful for the whole
experience yes I live in the purple
match I am it's so hard Lee's it's just
to find a mattress that understands you
you know right and that you understand
because sleep is important the quality
of your sleep affects the quality of
your daily life that's so true and a
great mood today
oh my god you're right the purple
mattress will probably feel different
than anything you've ever experienced
because it uses this brand-new material
that was developed by an actual rocket
scientist Yan musk it was not like the
memory foam that you're used to do you
know that purple was founded by two
brothers so I just tables it up
it was ever the purple material feels
very unique because it's both firm and
soft at the same time like he's must be
happy and sad at the same time so keeps
everything supported while still feeling
really comfortable plus it's breathable
so it sleeps cool you're going to love
purple and right now our listeners will
get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that's in
addition to the great free gifts that
they're offering site-wide just text
toast eight four eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is to text
toast to 848 that's TOA st to a four
eight four eight messaging data rates
may apply ok i just want to say I'm
really disappointed that you wore this
outfit today because it's very much an
Argentine t-shirt rest moment mosquito
fresh off the runway I'm scrambling and
she needed to see it tomorrow well
tomorrow I'm wearing her ShoeDazzle
shoes off it will revolve around the
shoes okay and I don't know that this
would look good with like a white satin
pearl pump you know I'm just saying like
it's berry I'm gonna have to wear my
wedding dress okay I think I'll wear my
prom dress just because I really want to
like her to feel like we're giving her
like the respect that she so desperately
deserve are you watching Theo are you
watching the live stream I'm watching
Theo I got a new dog camera okay when I
first got a dog I was like I need a dog
camera it went online like the one that
everyone has it's [ __ ] $200 and I'm
like you know what I'm not doing that
just like principle like stupid so about
the $50 one it was the Yee home camera
and it works for about six months before
it broke then I ordered another one
which is like a very odd like Japanese
company and it was also $50 and it broke
with like literally one day after using
it so I bought the $200 one and I ended
up spending a hundred more dollars if I
just hadn't been cheap in the first
place that's like what the head check
was telling us last night because yes
when you're buying nice ingredients
no when you're buying knives which are
very important to the culinary
experience there are the expensive ones
and there are the cheap ones and you're
going to be fine to buy the cheap ones
but they're gonna break in 6 they're
gonna be dull in six months if you buy
the expensive ones and you sparked
you'll have them for about ten years and
in the end you will actually have saved
money so what does he say to do about
rust on your knives he didn't even
mention it because I guess it's not a
thing most people struggle with but
dolna I know what they say about what
else he taught us how to sharpen our
knives how to hone the knife what you're
supposed to do every time you cook yours
but you know what they say about rust
our lives it's a knife cancer I've never
he didn't even mention it the son
mentioned
that's what they say anyway so then [ __ ]
at all my knife work is on point after
awesome did you learn to julienne I
bother to julienne Hoss
I'm good did you went to julianne moore
I learned to Juliet wow I learned it all
and I one time the one time that I
cooked with Olivia like all she asked me
to do was make the salad yes you know
prep and it took me so long it hurt my
wrist like it was so hard and I learned
how to chop last night and it really is
a skill and now like up who wants a
salad choppy Oh choppy Oh el Chapo's a
really is such an important skill so
yesterday was nice and choppy Oh next
week will be meat and like you know the
cooking and the following will be fish
and it's kosher
and it was kosher and I ate like a horse
did you make any friends I did well you
know the whole group we really I would
say became a family
overnight really and there's just a mere
three hours and by the way it ended
early he said next week in the following
week we'll take the whole three hours
but this class ended early and we got
fed it was really Jackie wanted me to
come and I was down but like the three
hours like you know what I could do with
three hours I did my taxes I know you
talked about calling it close April
fourth I have to do mine but Jackie and
Ben were both like on last night I'm
like okay I FaceTime to everyone I knew
you typica Benjamin we got them are
gonna pick up I'm like okay I will do my
taxes and I didn't realize how much work
I had in front of me excuse me because
we have to file our business I have to
file my personal business and then my
personal like income so like it was a
lot of work and I was really confused
and I called the accountant and he was
like it's April 4th and I was like I'm
sorry Mike please help me well you're
better off than I am though and I was
really wanting you to come to this class
for you and for me um and I would invite
you next week but I just feel like the
bond we've all form like I don't think
you'll fit in at this point do you think
they'd let me come if I didn't learn the
dnieper e and they would let you come
for sure and the head of marketing for
the JCC where it was is a toaster and
like knew I was coming to get private
lessons I don't know like well that's
what I was thinking like this chef is
really he was very patient and he was
very anxious to train you to know it was
a kinship between the class and like I
feel like there's a different there's
obviously like a difference between
being a pro and being good at being able
to teach people and he was very
educational but I just don't really feel
like I need to learn how to cook because
Ben's dad is a chef and I literally have
like full like fridges of like chicken
and salad and tuna and Bolognese it like
won't always be like that like what if
there's a storm you know and it's like
literally in the middle of a storm the
doorman will rig up I'd be like you're
in losses chopped on food like they
always drop off like platters like they
are literally just like the most Jewish
like concerning loving parents and
there's always food in my house well
that's nice and Ben is an excellent chef
as well okay then then you're okay but
like for us and the woman X we were all
talking about our levels of cousin she
was like I know enough not to starve and
I was like no I'm literally starving
your stove level when I like can't find
anything I want to order did you get
that Asus just start did you get that
you guys go to bed without supper
did you go to the juice you're Oliver
Twist did you get JCCC woman's contact
I'm sure it's in the bag of swag that I
got so I just feel like on MTC's we set
up a private class like just us sure
okay sure how could you get like a
little station we did it was really it
was really cute it was really cute it
was a really premium experience a TiVo a
nice job there at the JCC
okay and then can we request like things
to learn how to make but please no one
come to the next house because I liked
it intimate Oh actually penny when I
take it now is like a 3/4 you're meeting
like really like exclusive with your
cooking life just my like protect the
chef's
okay okay maybe I'll cook you something
sweet this is a shirt I got in Hudson
Yards yesterday it was
swanky as hell mean Jackie Webb and I
went into the dressing room which is
like the new mall in New York and it's
they have a Neiman Marcus and the
dressing room it has this huge iPad and
there's so many things you can scan an
item and request a different size I just
have it like brought to you without ever
having to talk to anyone beautiful they
have like five different lighting
options like natural candlelit
multicolored that's so beautiful
I do the natural the most unflattering
you know yeah like CNN source yeah I got
a dress it's really nice thank you and
then I got a dress for our toast
one-year anniversary party
it was Veronica beard and I was just
like whatever you're hammering Wes I was
just like what are weird name for her
brand oh well she wears that she makes
the cutest stuff and camera mascot is
always wearing it and camera mascot does
this thing where someone someone
compliments our outfit she feels the
need to say who it's by which I kind of
under me too I understand it I don't
know
what the cycle at we should talk to
Asher he's like what is that what is she
trying to you know mentally some people
are time like exception coming so they
put it notes don't thank me thank
Veronica right or just like giving
details to them to be like right yeah I
didn't turn said she's always wearing
Veronica beard well so slap my ass and
call me Kevin what Scott like those um
share clueless South had set her yeah
and that was just a weird was that
Veronica beer that was Veronica theory
the Whaley and took it made it weird no
way Lee Anne like went to the store and
bought the same outfit Leon's getting
married I know this in 21 days that's
immediate to Dallas probably and just
like do a live chose outside the church
he's being so public with where it is
it's actually wants people to show up
huh let's do it
we'll be there okay I think I think
we've wasted my time you have to you
like it's already 11 o'clock he got
further ado wait can you meet my mic I
have took off real bad please meet her
Mike without further ado here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast Snooki says Mike
the situation is having the time of his
life in prison huh Snooki is giving an
update on her Jersey Shore's co-stars oh
my god I mean online it says Jersey
store haha I love finding typos in like
real websites like ha ha ha it's been a
ton of actually will know if they watch
the toast if it gets corrected I mean
it'll get corrected just because I bet
every comment as i stiii actually don't
think someone it's from tuesday from
yesterday like they've had enough time
it's been a tough year for the Castaway
TV since we know she watches Melanie
Bromley he fixed the typo and also fix
your accent it's been a tough year for
the cast of the MTV reality show
including the situation who was
currently serving his eight months
prison sentence and JWoww who has been
going through a tough divorce with Roger
Matthews so how's everyone doing today
quote Jenny's doing amazing everyone's
going through their own [ __ ] right now
it's like we should have a reality show
you do with snippy shared bethey news
during an exclusive interview at her
store the smokey shop so jenny is doing
amazing obviously hard times but I've
never seen a more confident and happier
and you know just things don't work out
so hopefully everything will work out
they could co-parent and call it a day
as for how Mike is doing amid his time
in prison Stuckey told enews he's quote
having the time of his life it's like
his in a senior home he's playing bingo
he's helping people recover in jail we
all talked him through an email so I
talked to him like once a week he's in
the gym a lot so he's probably gonna
come out ripped you know he's not gonna
be BDS anymore Big Daddy snitch haha
he's gonna have his probably six-pack
again but he's doing he's doing good in
there they really need to get another
acronym for Big Daddy such because BDS
is like a vile anti-semitic organization
I was like did I just say BDS I have so
many thoughts about this I feel like
this is what prison is supposed to be
for like most people but like the gangs
ruin it but like it's really
rehabilitative you know mm-hmm
rehabilitate how deep rehabilitated I
was actually thinking like snitches
gonna come back you said Big Daddy
finish it at first no idea you did but I
knew what you meant but it's impossible
for me which is going to come out grips
from this because the food in jail isn't
that good and all there is to do was
work out better yourself and do yoga
look at Theresa write a book right so I
guess I should be really good for him
and like him just spreading the gospel
of like how to stay sober in prison like
that is kind of positive energy they
need I feel like okay you know how when
Carlos um went to prison or no when
Carlos got his sight back he wanted to
like devote his time to working with the
blind and Gaby was like no please get a
job this is gonna be like sick she's
gonna like love helping people so much
in prison that he's gonna become like it
like a sober like coach or something
sure like joel osteen know joel Oh Steve
is a pastor like a motivational speaker
Tony Robbins okay no no not in the
religious way but in a monisha okay Tony
Robbins was a better comparison like
Joel Osteen like no okay tomorrow we'll
see like had that big church like
wouldn't let people in um Jordan from
what Wall Street
Jordan Woods from wolf of Wall Street
majority third he went to he committed
he committed financial crimes he went to
prison motivational speaker makes you
think Bruce Jenner when the Olympics
motivational speaker it's just saying
how you become a motivational speaker it
seems like a last words work for some
people right it's either you have had
the highest high or the lowest low right
and that's what makes it motivational
right and that's what makes people like
how interested in listening to you you
know who should be a lot of a tional
speaker and she can learn how to speak
Kourtney Kardashian the lowest of lows
Ellison Olivia the highest of highs push
right I was
I watched her Vogue makeup tutorial ads
to die and I was infuriated
the rest of our I watched it on my TV
like because I have the YouTube app so I
can watch videos like the morning toast
wonderful morning show you guys should
look into it they go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube they're also available on the
podcast happens podcast Spotify iTunes
stitcher or whatever and it's all the
news that you need to know before you
wake up but take it might end up in the
morning toast and it's also all the news
thing you want to know also it's like
two cute girls who else if they happen
to be related both then were like super
skinny and pretty in town didn't like
everyone loved somebody show us of all
them and Instagram girls no job jackieo
problem and this is just me or they
getting skinnier and prettier every day
no so I watch her makeup tutorial
natural beauty which is the weird thing
to say because that's what you call
someone who is naturally beautiful and
so she keeps saying this was my I hope
you guys learned some ID remedies right
like it was just weird it's like organic
it's organic she does her makeup like
she was reminding me like a bolivia
where she puts on like her contour after
her bronze so that she puts bronzer as
foundation oh yeah she did put her
contour stick on afterwards right I
thought was interesting what she did
with her contour I didn't think it was
bad um anything was not either and it
was the only thing I saw that like made
a positive difference right and she was
like putting so much stuff on her face
before that she was getting so shiny it
was crazy I mean she was powdering it
wasn't help it she really always is
shiny but if you like that wound all of
us Instagram hoes for our highlighter
she's like I don't like that that
contour highlighting kidding me I can go
through her Instagram and find so many
photos where she's makeup by arielle
with also are you [ __ ] kidding me
like that's her entire sisters brand
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] on it right and it's
like I was just waiting for her to talk
about then the the Q score of her sister
is cosmetic right that dumb a poor she's
like I haven't checked the score cuz
like I'm afraid you know it was so dumb
and like maybe this was my favorite part
she was saying how she usually doesn't
like to do glam but when she gets it
done she likes to be productive so
she'll sit in the glam chair getting her
hair done but then you know work work
and when she was explaining like what
she does like for work she literally
couldn't think of saying things to say
she was like so I mean like any my clam
and I'll just like try to be like
productive like you know I'm like watch
die cuts of our show and like she
watches TV and like you know just like
take calls
she's so shy she calls her friends
because I'm where she yes she literally
couldn't think of things to describe
like what work is you know right it
really highlighted like how little she
works right and I just the video really
made me like what has she done I want to
see Chloe's makeup routine me too
because she really changes her face but
you know I'm sorry to me is interesting
I would like to see Kris Jenner right
Kris Jenner never does her makeup
there's no way I'm like her mixing
things in her bathroom like it's a
kitchen yes she is honey and like the
honey was making me so like nervous for
her life if it gets in your hair like
your whole days ruined yeah but I did
like how our toilets she had two toilets
and symmetrical where you sit is covered
yeah and that it's just like really nice
I was one of them a bidet no I'm sure
it's like his and hers that shouldn't
max like do dreams have separate but
she's single like but her home she still
like yeah it's still a family what value
she ever wants to sell it to toilets
will make it worth more no I love seeing
people's bathrooms I think it's wildly
interesting I hate and then I hate when
people are obviously doing it in hotels
because they don't want to like show
they're rather right I felt like this
was her bathroom 100% I hate when they
do it in hotels - who else do you want
to see makeup from um I just don't want
to see models or like people who don't
wear makeup
I better be honest was so interesting
this because she's like gorgeous but
where's like Instagram thick foundation
Fenty like I just like when people
actually had build on their makeup not
people who are like chapstick and call
it lip gloss like that's not chapstick
it's medicinal
right - the whole thing is like
sponsored they're using all the brands
that they're sponsored by so it's like
do you even use this or a de Neutrogena
pee
you know I want to sue and his vote get
it kind of that hundred percent I really
would just want to see people who like
have pimples and need to cover them up
you know like right like honestly I
wanna see Bella Thorne right she covers
her skin up good and that's helpful yeah
I was he real people like I can't like
watching like actually never had a
really interesting one Jasmine tooks
she wears like a good about her makeup
oh I didn't see it yeah I like that one
and she was like on vacation she just
like was like freckly she looked at you
but I just um I don't need to see models
doing their makeup like they don't wear
makeup when I say inspired me to make
another makeup tutorial yeah once I'm
moving out home a new bathroom that like
but I had two toilets no it only has one
but if she thinks I don't has one toilet
you know but like you in spades steps to
pinks that's pretty cool it's a bit it's
a step up that's pretty cool me and Ben
have two sinks no and I just found out
let you days ago we just used the same
one that's so funny that's like when we
were living together for six months we
found out we were using the same
toothbrush you know who you and I Oh
oh yeah but like we're sisters anything
knows that gross that is
I don't even want to use my own
toothbrush you know did we go through
any stories you know just one okay
next up a little more MTV News the hills
new beginnings finally gets premiere
date I'm sorry the hills old footage and
one photo shoot gets a premiere date the
hills new beginnings may still be in
reshoots but an airdate is now in sight
MTV announced on Tuesday that the hills
reboot will premiere on Monday June 24th
the network also released the first look
at the series which is a combination of
old chill footage and a montage of the
new cast okay which is a combination of
old chill footage and the cast got a
photo shoot right so it's an hour and 18
I mean it's a minute and 18 seconds and
up until 54 seconds it's old footage and
just like words then the remaining like
22 seconds is them at a photo shoot
didn't show ones things like what we're
gonna see for oh they they showed us
Audrina and Justin Bobby cheering to
being friends like I want to vomit
nobody needs the show absolutely no one
no I honestly if we're gonna show for
it's for Spencer and Heidi and they
should have just given them their own
show agreed they don't need to be cast
with Mischa Barton even though I'm like
located looking forward to be here the
people who were the hills fans so like
us aren't interested in the show like
aren't interested in watching like
Whitney port just like be brand safe
I like making organic diapers right and
like she is like that's who she is but
like she wasn't interesting on the show
then like she has a nice life for
herself now I don't want to watch her
them try and put her in compromising
position
totally she's brand safe she was bred
safely so was Audrina yeah like she was
wrecking a pregnancy announcement was
sponsored by like a test why did you
just go pee test yeah yeah clearly
whichever one so no the people who used
to watch the show don't need it the
people who never watch the show don't
know who they are
and I just I just think this is highly
unnecessary and it's our going together
all these people who don't even know
each other they these people have been
hung out in years how does Mischa Barton
even fit into the mix she only fits into
the mix because she starred on the show
that spawned this show again it'd be
like teri hatcher going on the other
house I totally get it but like which is
cool at the end of the day that is not a
show make right
she doesn't know these people and the
best shows are run people that's why
Shahs of Sunset it's a great a show on
television that nobody pays attention to
it's because these people been friends
for like 20 years they went to high
school
it's like those real intimate
relationships and history between the
people is what makes the reality show
great and that's also why Kardashian's
in total Bella's are great shows because
when you get a family like that's
already built in that's also why this
show is so great right if you've heard
of it it's called morning toast yeah um
I am kind of interested to see birdie
and his wife because they seem like cute
and instagramming yeah they see buddy
definitely on a reality show about like
young couples in a in LA like not having
anything to do with the hills weight and
we know that the hills is scripted like
they oh they pulled back the curtain on
that one we also know that the hills are
alive with the sound of music so are
these people gonna be acting in which
case I didn't know that oh that's why we
should barn is Eric she's an actress
maybe maybe I didn't know Frankie
Delgado was an actor I don't even know
who that it's something new every day he
was like Brody's friend Frankie and now
he's the main character so I don't know
him anyways I'm not gonna be watching
because one I don't have MTV and two
even if I did I don't want to support
this I don't want someone on MTV to
think that this was the right move you
know my talking is full when it comes to
reality shows and I just can't take
anything on at this point it's not like
super fortunate but they could have made
they should have brought back the hills
with like 20 and 21 year olds in young
Hollywood now yeah like so many
interesting crews or like how they be
connected like Heidi's sisters cousin
you know like they couldn't like how
Sheena was like the connection between
betta from pearls in Beverly Hills right
or it could have been like Brody's
little sister Kylie's friends yeah yeah
no no or like Brody's wife's little
sisters friends like I'm sure she came
from eiko Malibu crew I'm sure they
could have found one connection just one
yeah and that's like I would start
anything like I could go for a new the
hills cast but this is just I'm so
unnecessary Oh dirty water and it's a
little stale
yeah if you ask me but in some more
positive hills news Lauren prep Conrad
is pregnant with her second child
she just has like the best life she does
but you know she will be so rich like I
would look to understand her financials
you know yeah she grew up rich and those
financials have her husband right
because he's like a musician in a band
nobody's ever heard of yeah yeah and she
is like this huge I think she makes a
lot of money like with her books and her
side her whole brand her paper crown
yeah but I think she got a nice leg up
just like you know having her parents
pay her rent for a while yeah but that
runs out quick
don't say anything that she has in her
bank account has to do with her parents
yeah but just have a to do with her
husband I don't know no I don't think so
but like they just seem really cute and
like they have their priorities in order
yes she's like so uninterested in ever
being a part of us we're even
reality TV she could have a reality show
yeah but I just interesting like who
thinks they're above it and like I would
think Whitney port would think she's
above this low-level trash show me too
but she's married to a nice boy and
entrepreneur and I just think that like
she is above it and I thought she would
think she's above it too
agreed maybe opportunities are running
dry right maybe the paparazzi weren't in
a helicopter above her wedding which
meant that she had to get a job
according to the retina which is
honestly like makes me rethink like
there was no paparazzi at mine or your
wedding because they were indoor true or
girl with no job her husband is a lawyer
I thought it was a musician
uh I think he's a musician I guess we
could google him
William toe William Tell no I swear he's
a music she's a folk hero of Switzerland
that can't be right William Tell Lauren
Conrad right but now I'm gonna just get
like babies help cause we're gonna be on
it no he's a musician yeah though
Bosworth is gonna be on it he's formed
something corporate oh that's like you
know I'm like Dashboard Confessional
like I don't say Dashboard Confessional
can [ __ ] rock out with their [ __ ]
out here you have stolen my huh I have a
sore throat so I can't really hit high
notes today I managed to hit the note
anyway uh ready for the next story sure
Joe Jonas had to sign an NDA when he
learned the game of Thrones ending yeah
that's about ah mostly just wanted to
talk about Game of Thrones even Joe
Jonas had to sign legal documents to
make sure he remained quiet after
learning how a game of Thrones ends
quote he was actually on set for most of
it so he kind of figured it out sophie
turner said of her fiance i'm Good
Morning America on Tuesday then he had
to sign an NDA Turner added he had to
have like full photo approval his camera
was covered up everything about what
like maybe if he's sitting at her
dressing room watching like they won't
they wouldn't let him take pictures I
don't know when asked if Jonas is gonna
keeping secrets she laughed and said no
his terror
it's a lovin lovin make-a-wish chances
for the boys just for the boys just for
the boys just for boys I would like to
feel better and I would also like a
Netflix special and I hope tomorrow's
interview you know just we get out of
Park become friends for a lifetime
yeah totally that's a good one um you
have to take the wishes as they come you
know I always think how like Game of
Thrones is probably the best show that
like has never had a spoiler never had
anything leaked and there's like
theories and stuff and most of them are
wrong and the theories are really like a
fanfiction but it's super impressive
it's super impressive a lot of like if
you go down already the whole day
probably someone has figured it out
because also in every episode and
especially in the first episodes they
tell you what is going to happen right
their heads but it's so [ __ ]
confusing with all the names right so
people really have figured it out um but
if you don't read into it too much you
don't know what's coming but then once
you know what's gonna happen and you
look back you're like of course I was
gonna happen
ya know but I find like when people call
things out to be annoying like last
season I was watching with Ben and when
the dragon died and then they Ben's like
they're gonna make it a white Walker and
then they did I was like annoyed because
like I would have rather had the real
moment than Ben figure it out I never I
did not figure that out until they were
pulling him by the chain yeah that was
crazy totally and it's like if they
never went over there they would have
never been able to across the wall right
but it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
that's like that was really stupid to me
because the wall really did work also
the wall worked and also like why did
they just fire on those Dragons down and
have it stare on the wall and breathe
fire and anyone who even came within
like 100 miles because fire is the only
thing that can kill White Walkers and
Dragons like [ __ ] breathe fire right
so it just seemed like silly yeah it
sort of it all had cellphones this
could've been so much better coordinated
but the fact that I checked like six
months to get a message from like Jon to
Daenerys no but like the Ravens
definitely got read the last season
because they were moving fast you know
the person was stranded on an island and
Daenerys came through in the first
season it was like we've got to get this
message in like the first episode it
comes to her season three and yeah and a
part of like the excitement was like
directed hasn't gotten there yet and now
it's like finally they got Wi-Fi yeah
and the [ __ ] was being lit yeah no it
really did it moved along I think they
heard our cries I like how Game of
Thrones they sort of like listen to what
the fans
or say I think it's so interesting that
they made him sign an NDA I wonder who
else knows what do you think the ending
is I don't know don't say it please and
I don't want to choke I don't think I
know but like not everyone can live oh
he's that yo check it I really don't
want you to just figure it out I really
don't want you to like ruin it and I
just want to like enjoy this season and
I'm gonna watch them alone because like
I'm not one of those people who like
needs to figure it out I just want to
watch it like be shocked like oh okay
[ __ ] what's the show big little lies
spoiler alert if you didn't see it
plug your ears oh you ruined this for me
yeah because my [ __ ] friend Alicia
ruined it for me because I was on like
season 1 and episode 1 and she was like
you know what I think she's like I think
that Perry was the guy who raped Shane a
crime no ashaming Woodley and I'm like
what are you talking about there's no
way like the silhouette of the guy is so
sure he looks like he has red hair like
there's literally no way I'm like that
I'm like Elise yeah your job like that
isn't there's no way lo and behold
pairing is the rapist and I'm like I
even shared with you guys like how does
this be really but what's so crazy about
me is like I never even thought or
attempted to try and figure out who did
it I was like she was right right and
like I just really take things that they
saw I'm like it will always haunt her
right and that's her cross to bear truly
but I never thought it would come full
circle I kinda tried to figure it out I
really would have been shocked at
speaking of crosses to bear Jackie last
night experience firsthand what in this
lifetime is what my cross to bear is
just to remember like I have to go back
to the past no you don't have to say you
didn't have to say it was the class you
just feel like someone come objection
oh right okay obviously no right I don't
want you to feel ugly great we'll talk
about it in three weeks time yeah yeah
okay next story Harry and Megan have
launched an Instagram account called
Sussex royal with already two and a half
million followers it am i mean this
although smaller than me but um it hit a
new record look the fastest Instagram
account to get to a million followers I
think the previous record was like 11
minutes I did in 7 Wow
yeah um so just like me those numbers up
but it's something like that the name of
it is the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and
bio is an official Instagram account of
the Duke industrial of Sussex
that is so hard to say logo it makes so
much sense okay I just want to say yes
but their logo looks like it was made on
canva like I look like it was a looks
like a time playing hmm yes it's like a
template that they just like drop their
initials in right they said quote
welcome to our official Instagram we
look forward to sharing the work that
drives us the causes we support
important announcements and the
opportunity to shine light on key issues
we thank you for your support and
welcome you to act Sussex Royal Harry
and Megan this is just like so like
lowbrow like Kate Middleton is not over
here like worrying about an Instagram
account she's worrying about like the
future of her nation you know and I
think that's the problem and I think
some would argue that Instagram is
crucial to the future of the nation and
they have to find a way it was just like
when radio came out and then the Queenie
vibe is doing like Christmas talks on
the radio she had to adapt to the times
and at the time she thought that that
was insane but they have an Instagram
they have at Kensington Palace no but
like I don't think they need like sub
brands of their Instagram like sharing
our announcements like just a release of
president I think I think this is the
few and it is the future they have to
get on board in like the Royals have
always struggled to modernize I think
Megan Willow 8 like will be on the
forefront of their modernization and I
think that this is just step one like
Eugenie made an Instagram a year ago and
she's [ __ ] popping off you were the
one who told me that it's you janae all
right you badge Ania Doubtfire dear you
journey made an Instagram and like now
she has a direct line of communications
with her constituent yeah but she's like
she's not a royal were like they are
actually she's more in line to the
throne than Megan no she's legit she's
no but I think she should have an intern
I'm like them having like a family and
stir criminals looking lame I just think
this is going slow yeah just know when
it comes to any time I talk about Megan
Markel like I'm just jealous of her yeah
like when I was being fun of her wedding
dress which by the way was ugly um
people were like you're so mean you're
jealous
Megan I'm like duh she's a [ __ ]
princess I'm jealous that Megan could
have any dress in the world that you
wanted and she chose that one that's
what's up and didn't and chose not to
get a tailored right that's what I'm
jealous of imagine being so confident
that like you buy a dress like don't
tailor it for your wedding I have a
[ __ ] dress here that I'm tailoring
right after this because like my boob
for 2ik
that will always like being your cross
we're having boobs too big oh of course
but I just meant like her wedding dress
will always it's kind of like Grace
Kelly that's me because you think you
have Megan Marco figured out it's like
she went from hallmark taken jinkin
palace it's like oh guys like we've
never seen before and so when you get
there and it's your wedding day like a
you assume like you're just gonna
[ __ ] slay this day and like you were
that I just don't understand the choice
yeah no it's kind of not like Grace
Kelly like when people like to ascribe
their wedding dresses so like I want the
Grace Kelly moment even Kate Middleton
like both iconic dresses that like for
years to come people will be comparing
like their wedding inspiration to and
just like it'll be famous for the dress
and Megan Marco has the same effect but
just totally in a negative way yeah it's
like if I took my if I was getting
married and I went to the seamstress and
she look what kind of fits you why do I
like give me the anti Megan Markoff or
give me the magnet mark on them it's
just like a big smock right or if I'm go
to art class what kind of a smock you
want I'll take the Megan mark all
you know I wore an apron last night
right did you where's Megan the mega
mark on a print I know I actually taste
made it really tight yeah it was fifty
yeah cute super cute okay fifth and
final story little business Bitcoin
prices are soaring again Bitcoin prices
shot up 15% Tuesday and briefly rose to
above the five thousand dollar level for
the first time since November but good
luck finding a reason to explain the
sudden spike nigel green founder and
chief executive to their group simply
said in a report that quote there is a
growing sense that bitcoin is back did
it ever be didn't it just come
no it was definitely gone i feel like
every day last year we were talking
about it i don't forgot their password
right and then like now i don't even I
haven't heard that coin in years Bitcoin
reshape I think crypto is really where
time I watched the show called Queen of
the South and like she's like the
Daenerys Targaryen of drug lords like my
doing sister out here like doing the
reality show no it's it's like far goes
okay because I've never watched narco so
I'm assuming it's far coast and she the
way she distributes her drugs is like
very technologically savvy and she gets
all of her but she keeps all her money
in cryptocurrency so she can go anywhere
like no one could ever steal from her
because like she has a [ __ ] hardware
for my clothes it needs to be
like her it's really but so okay so she
does all this cryptocurrency and she
went to go to Bergdorf's like how does
she pay um she has a bank I don't know I
don't she doesn't actually show she
doesn't look like she shots heparin it's
like having a lot of monopoly money you
know it's a Giudice monopoly let me have
target no no but like you can get it
transfer two dollars it is in dollars
just confusing that's all I'm saying
green added that this dramatic jump is
likely to attract many investors who've
been sitting on the sidelines if that's
you I guess this would be the time to
invest in Bitcoin except I'm not here to
make stock suggestion so what are the
bets in some you know invest in
something when it's at its height I want
to invest in something you know I feel
like I've had a good year and I have
like some extra cash and I want to like
Joe not donate it lol like I mean maybe
I should that's where my priorities are
just [ __ ] up but I want to invest in
something like that I think that has
potential you know but I don't really
know I'm not like in tune people are
never pitching me now people are gonna
pinch my foot why don't you messing it
host I do [ __ ] I'm here it's like we
did investors of the choice like in the
very beginning and it has paid off like
yeah emotionally and also monetarily
right and we'll talk all about that like
the Genesis via Genesis on our toast
anniversary on Tuesday I'm excited for
that job too who knows I believe in do
news stories ya know maybe would you
like the five things I learned or yeah
oh that's cute from becoming a business
owner that's really cute
taxes are [ __ ] you already are investor
in toes so you should say in addition to
my current investment of the morning
comes right
I would like to invest I think in like
definitely something digital but
direct-to-consumer brand maybe like if I
wear I don't think they need my money no
and I don't think I want that like type
of brand association but and it's like
the weirdest choice you could have me
you know I was just thinking like an
Instagram brand like you know equip
those toothbrushes that I [ __ ] do so
well yeah they're just like toothbrushes
at six your mirror I don't understand
I wouldn't recommend them honestly I
have them okay um you know what you
could invest in hotels in some socks
okay how often do you think about your
socks all the time if you're like I used
to be not much but recently discovered
socks that will change the way you think
my socks forever unless you are me
they're called BOM bus
um vamos have most comfortable socks in
the history of feet they're made from
super soft natural cotton every pair
comes with arch support a seamless toe
and a cushioned footbed that's comfy but
not too thick I hope you do you know
that for like six months I was wearing
socks that were just a little too small
and they were giving me toe problems you
were gonna become like one of those
women with bound feet right and so I
finally got bomba socks and not only
their comfortable that they were
properly sized yeah I have been flat
feet and this is perfect for it I have
flat feet as well
tights genetic probably probably buy
your bomba socks at bombas comm slash
toes today and get 20% off your first
purchase
that's B om bas comm slash chose for 20%
off bum bus comm slash toast I feel like
people really overlook socks and the
importance and I think that should end
today I thought my circumcised off I
feel like we can never and you know
enroll in the army because oh my god are
you seeing this thing okay there is a
Taylor Swift fan account that was like
I'm very popular like her fan accounts
become like media outlets for her like
many times she spotted and this girl
like went missing and she's like a
really popular Twitter account and
finally she tweeted like hey guys
sorry I haven't been active I've been in
prison so it went viral and then she
tweeted again she was like my friend
came to visit me I'm still in prison
but I had her like released a message to
you guys and someone was like why is she
in prison and you I don't know why
because she lives in Israel and she did
want to go to the army so she dodged the
drafting I put in prison oh my god how
funny is that
that's hilarious yeah just like funny
you know worlds colliding hmm
real houses Beverly Hills I held my
tongue long enough I mean I can't I
thought that this iconic moment would be
like the season finale because they
showed it in the very beginning of the
season so I thought it wouldn't be for a
while
but I'm like loving that it's just right
here right now and it was wild I mean
the fact that Lisa Vanderpump didn't
show up to I mean I do have to say I've
never went to defend Lisa Vanderpump but
I thought what Lisa Rinna said about her
not riding the bike was really mean what
did she say what do you mean no she's
not gonna cycle with us like it was just
like a mean skinny like mean girl thing
to say yeah like you know except I was
he was like a little age Shanee but then
I was like no breathe Lisa Rinna's
pretty old
even open Lisa Vanderpump wasn't gonna
ride not because she's not in shape it's
because she's older like it was both I
don't want to touch I'm gonna see what
the difference in ages because Lisa bent
like everybody how they are left like I
thought that was really mean
okay it was mean fine you're right Lisa
Vanderpump age 58 Lisa Rinna 55 Kyle
Richards 50 hold on Erika Jayne 47 Denis
48 Teddy 37 Wow Teddy's so young yeah
Teddy's younger than Jax Taylor Teddy
went to high school with Shep yeah they
grew up together
I've been following Teddy on Instagram
forever and I just like she's we started
hanging out her dad a lot and like it's
really nice like they have like such a
nice life she has like this huge house
in Florida and they like go to his
concert take a private chat like back to
the compound in Florida and the kids
just like love going in the pool and
begun the lake it looks really I'd love
to see that side of her work yeah I'm
private jet and he like was singing Jack
and Diane you know that's cute back to
the task at hand
yeah great yeah they definitely that
wasn't me I didn't like that it was mean
and there were a few issues obviously
I'm here for the recommend we've been
here for the reckoning ever since we sat
down in these chairs and these Thrones
but there are a few issues with the way
that the reckoning has come first of all
the story's a little thin and at the end
of the day it's about the welfare of an
animal and a lot of people are able to
argue that what directed is worse than
anything that Vanderpump has done right
and what we're talking about now is so
stupid because it never would have
happened to rate had it made the mistake
right I personally don't agree with that
I I think during - nothing wrong I think
she was just trying to help like a
foster in animal and it just went south
you know I think should there have
anything wrong but she could have
handled it a lot better and like she
doesn't she's not an animal abuser by
any means but she was a little negligent
so I think that they picked the wrong
sword to fall on in general and then
second I mean the way that everything
went down in this episode where the
women are not saying olive and Lisa
Vanderpump is getting like resolutions
passed in Congress that was right save
animals like it just couldn't look worse
for them we know I actually like got
chills well first of all but they didn't
know what they said I was that was so
fun either I did it pass or not that was
hilarious and I thought that was great
and like it's really hard for me to
separate listed in her pup from like the
wonderful philanthropic ventures that
she you know embarks on while also being
like the
feeling a [ __ ] that she is you know and
like in in live tweeting the episode
last night and just like responding to
people on Twitter like she's only
talking about the dog thing and it's
like what she does is amazing but it's
irrelevant to the storyline but also
like what she doesn't for dogs is
amazing but the way that she treats
humans is horrible like in any situation
on this show like she's she treats
humans worse like than animals and then
she only has special compassion for
animals it's weird it's really because
she obviously has this like very soft
spot in her like she's a very
compassionate person but not to people
yeah totally it's weird so I didn't
think it was weird that she didn't show
up because like first of all I just
didn't like how they were all to be like
it's the only basis $8,500 like that was
mean to like please know and when she's
considering canceling the ride but
didn't want to look petty like Teddy
went to all of this work to raise money
for free Artie how would it even cross
it she should have been there yeah she
liked that what I thought that was so
pushing stuff by before yes of course
and obviously she's not gonna get on a
bike she doesn't have to but to stop by
before like show your face I thought
that was so [ __ ] up it's like all
these women are [ __ ] spinning to
raise money for you for you you can't
even show up and then you're gonna make
them all look bad right by being like
doing your 401 and like and then saying
that they didn't come to your thing
because you didn't invite them that was
me or to being like that nobody came she
invited Kyle the night before it's
almost like she created this event the
night before so she would have a reason
not to go to the cycle anything and
invited Kyle just cuz she's the only one
she's still friends with yeah I'm really
interested to see where Denise Richards
it's gonna fall well next week it looks
like Denise Richards is in tune with
what's necessary right she has Danner
comes number she is like I don't want to
get on her bad side that's [ __ ] it
seems crazy said she's not gonna get in
it what she's not gonna take down or pub
side blindly just cuz she's been nicer
what a great question for her to ask she
said one thing I that meal it was a
great question well Kyle in the years
that you've known Lisa do you think that
this is something she would do a very
astute observation Denise Richards yeah
but like when Lisa is saying to Kyle
like I swear on my children's life like
that she did not do this and no one in
her camp did this like
how can she be lying I know you know and
that's what I felt like she was trying
to say - Lisa - Kyle is like if you
really think I'm lying and that's eaten
like Robbie week and my friend which is
true but it's like I may be that there's
a way that that statement taste of truth
but that she also did it you know it was
like with Moloch and said to Lisa like
no I am NOT dating a married human being
I was like okay I dating a married alien
you're dating a separated human being
yeah or you're dating a married alien
right there's ways of wording things I
don't think Kyle went there with any
intention that was like bad you know I
think in the car she was like looking
like grey in the face if she did not
want to be having that conversation but
she really went over there with good
intentions to be like hey I just got
back from the Sun where everyone's
talking [ __ ] about you thinking you're
this manipulative whatever like honestly
they made a compelling argument and she
was like I defended you as much as I
could but I couldn't really because I
don't know what you did in what you
didn't do so can you just tell me and
then Lisa's defended like saying but it
doesn't add up with what's going on and
I just little else could have planted
that article I saw on Twitter actually I
have to get a lot of mom think it's Lisa
Rinna some people said that producers
did it to stir up drama but I don't work
like that they I don't think they've
ever done anything like that I don't
think that they ever would write and
Radar Online is like so Lisa
Vanderpump's likes Jem right and then
thinking that she's that manipulative to
sell the story but then also go to TMZ
and be like really compassionate genius
she is that manipulative people they're
crazy to think that no but that's
actually what Lisa Vanderpump would do
right I just have to say my biggest she
would go to all of these links because
she's so hurt that Dury gave up this
animal because she cares about animals
more than it's not like she cares about
her image more than she cares about her
friendship she cares about animals more
than she cares about her friends and
also I just have to talk about the Ken
Vanderpump up at all because he's out of
control I mean for years he's been
having these like outbursts like when he
called Yolanda at that pool party a
stupid stupid woman
nuts getting his little finger in
everyone's face he's out of control and
the fact that he has something called
out more is nuts cuz like they used to
call out PK for being like so it's even
we have the diamond yeah like [ __ ]
the Ken Danner from Todd's out of
control first of all don't yell at a
woman like that second of all you're
wrong and three I'm seeing the LVP
stands like coming out in defending lee
sin can be like they politely ask
I'm like I mean last s Kyle asleep I'm
like hmm do we watch the same show cuz
it's not what happened
Ken minimum Todd is out of control if he
ever got in my face like that I would
[ __ ] yeah he's so scary he's so scary
because he lit his face was turning like
purple but it looks like next week is
pretty low-key like where do we go from
here I mean like being kicked out of
someone's house like I'm sure Kyle just
felt like awful
so awkward awkward embarrass on oh yeah
it was terrible it was terrible I just I
can't I but you know what I need to say
on Twitter because like everyone on
Twitter is always like wrong and crazy
about everything you know what so crazy
things realizing the episode was all one
day that's never happened yeah because
they went till they went to the ride
then they went to lunch and then she
went in the same outfit to Lisa's house
and then my question was they came to
the ride in glam and then they were glam
at lunch and they sweated a little
there's no way they showered and did
fresh clams no I think that it was a
shortened class yeah so they just put on
nice clothes over there swag because you
see Kyle like she was brushing out her
hair it's like they weren't that sweaty
yeah also I'd like to a lot of the women
like admitted that they were struggling
and SoulCycle like I've been to a
cycling class and felt like mortified
that like I was the only one who
couldn't keep up and like the fact that
Erika Jayne was like I gotta pretend
like I loved that yeah and who was dying
Denise
should I do Pilates like not she's in
such good shape I know her arms but the
fact that she also couldn't keep up like
made me feel better
relatable bunch of women totally I'm
just like I'm loving this season I just
really want to know is am I in the
majority and the minority when it comes
to being on everyone else's side okay if
you go on Twitter you're in the minority
if you talk to like normal people who
don't take to Twitter and just like I'm
gonna do come on their morning show and
talk about it I made you a pole I think
we're pretty 5050 um but I also think
that justice will be served for us imma
do pull my Instagram where do we stand I
mean what looks so ugly but like I feel
like the women keep saying every time
they do an interview like just way you
know justice more has to happen more
will come but I feel like they expected
more people to be on their side at this
point yeah what yeah what else is gonna
happen unclear it doesn't look like
there's they haven't teased anything
else major the only thing that could
really seal the deal is
at the Reunion but they haven't even
filmed the reunion yet so how could they
even be you know what I think we need
the head of Ray or online to come yes
Iver see but the thing is is they never
weapon even if they did the person who
who leaked the story wouldn't be LVP it
would be like a baby's cousins brothers
assistant right but then it could be
traced back but I don't think for your
online Everwood especially if it is LBP
shall either pay them or she like has
leverage she's a scary [ __ ] okay I put
on my story you like to see what side
people are on I just really want to get
the temperature of the of the world but
it's like everyone stands Lisa Rinna up
until it's time to like take up for her
you know yeah
P like I got lit surrender like the
dancing videos right on a [ __ ] table
against Lisa Rinna's a follower hi you
just want to see town I'll be P no this
isn't like all the women hi Nina isn't
like really upset me that's like such a
mean thing to say okay totally okay well
we got rosters of New York tonight
we also Ben's birthday dinner alright
I'll be there yeah I'm gonna be Steve at
me too and we're also gonna have lunch
at that's right I guess so yeah okay I
don't want like for soup like I really
love a lunch it was just like I was
maybe and I like be productive today but
I guess it could wait until tomorrow
okay no what's wrong
why do today why do today what you can
put off till tomorrow thank you guys for
being here at the morning toast the
Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube so make sure to
subscribe to the morning toast YouTube
which is the morning toast I mean no
it's youtube.com slash the morning show
so give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast podcast on
iTunes Spotify stitcher Public Radio
anyway you can listen to podcasts so
feel free to sis where I test there
leave as five stars talk about how
beautiful in skinny in pretty we are
that is all we have for you I'll be in
clearwater and our lender this weekend
so make sure to get your tickets at girl
bow job calm ass how me attacking your
problems by
you